out of all the streaming services Disney
plus has had one of the most Rocky Roads
from launch and it turns out that the
behind the scenes of the platform is a
lot more dire than we could have
imagined I've been gearing up to do an
overall Disney plus breakdown video but
the thing that really springboarded this
into existence is a new article released
by The Hollywood Reporter that sheds
light on a lot of major issues behind
the scenes that have been negatively
impacting MCU shows so I'll be covering
a lot of information revealed from this
article while also rounding up numerous
other articles that go into the
controversies behind the scenes and I'll
link all this information into General
big issues with Disney Plus's content
strategy for the MCU and Star Wars so
the first and most damning Revelation
brought up by The Hollywood Reporter is
that none of the MCU shows have had
actual showrunners first I should
probably describe the role of a
showrunner because it can get a little
confusing as to who's in control of the
Creative Vision given so many positions
like directors writers producers and
executive producers set have a saying
how a show is made the showrunner
essentially has full creative authority
over a series and manages every aspect
about a show from the writing filming
and editing and it's up to them if they
want to personally be involved with
writing and directing certain episodes
producers and executive producers are
technically higher on the food chain but
their creative input entails finding
people to work on a project and
supervise the process to see if
everything is running smoothly and is
also on budgets however Marvel on the
other hand didn't even bother with
acquiring showrunners they generally
approached directors and asked them to
pitch shows and they were normally not
heavily involved with the writing
process the primary director of
moonnight muhamad diab said he was
approached out of the blue by Marvel and
asked for him to pitch the series from
here they didn't actually make him the
showrunner and brought on more creatives
to help lighten the workload luckily
moonight is an example of this actually
working to a degree but a bad example
where this was a similar case was secret
Invasion now now it was largely a
mystery as to why secret invasion was so
expensive and looked the least
remarkable and most cheap of the MCU
shows but it turns out that the show was
utterly plagued with production issues
and had a staggering 4 months of
re-shoot along with the producers
bringing on a new writer during that
period to write new material so they
essentially remade a solid chunk of
secret invasion in that time to go into
more detail behind the scenes for secret
Invasion the worrying sign started with
Kyle Brad street writing scripts for the
show for almost a year until Marvel
spontaneously decided that they wanted
to take the show in a different
direction and drop kicked him out of the
series they hired a few directors and a
new writer and allegedly none of them
got along during pre-production it was
an absolute storm as this
unproductive crew worked inefficiently
and by a certain point they were burning
through their allotted schedule to the
point that they lost one of the
directors due to scheduling conflicts
forcing alium to now direct every
episode on top of most of the people
working on the show getting replaced the
Marvel executive who was overseeing
secret Invasion upseted the company so
much to the point that his contract will
not be getting renewed so secret
invasion was an absolute nightmare
behind the scenes and I think it's one
of the straws that broke the camel's
back for Marvel and realizing that this
model is not sustainable along with it
fundamentally delivering a worse product
because by having so many conflicting
creative opinions the show will feel
like a mess as everyone tries to get on
the same page secret invasion was this
hideous Franken signed baby that failed
to deliver on the premise of the show
and was this weird mashup of crappy spy
Espionage half as paranoia and so much
more that I dive into for a 20 minute
video I'll put in the end screen if
you're interested oh
Lord SW then there's also the issue that
Disney didn't hire on more Marvel
Executives to oversee TV shows that
suddenly landed on the doorsteps because
of Disney Plus instead the existing
Executives working for Marvel had to
split their time between the movies and
the show show which this piece of
information to me is a major reason why
Marvel has quickly been going off a
cliff in terms of quality they
essentially doubled their output of
Marvel content overnight and they were
clearly not ready to handle the massive
amount of work because before this they
had two or three movies a year they had
to worry about along with those movies
just being around 2 hours so actually
they more than tripled the amount of
content they had to worry about because
the shows generally run for around 4 to
5 hours like you'd probably be surprised
if I told you in 2021 Disney plus
released five MCU shows at a certain
point there must have been well over a
dozen Marvel projects being worked on at
a single time from here Kevin faky
probably couldn't be as involved as he
would want to be with most of these
projects it seems like he put his faith
in the creatives despite their not being
showrunners so the scripts clearly
deteriorated and there have been a
plethora of writing problems on almost
every MCU project coming up especially
blade which seems to be in a Perpetual
hell of writing now the proof that
points to Kevin foggy most likely not
having enough supervision over MCU
content is what just happened with
Daredevil born again this event was a
major talking point for The Hollywood
Reporter article it reveals Marvel
firing all the writers and directors on
the series because fogy disliked the
direction and quality of the show
funnily enough the writer strike
actually gave fogi some breathing room
and allowed him to fully review the
first four episodes that were shot
before the production shut down and
since he didn't like what he saw which
apparently Matt Murdoch doesn't actually
put on his suit until episode 4 and it
was just a legal drama basically he hit
the reset button on the show so
thankfully the strike led to more great
things besides giving writers
significantly better contracts the
strike saved a fan favorite show from
possibly another secret Invasion esque
fate without the strike it's likely that
this show would have continued shooting
without a guarantee as to whether it
would have been good generally in
television you would make a pilot
episode which would act as the first
episode of the series that you would
then show to the producers to Greenlight
the rest of the season or if they didn't
like the pilot they'd save money and say
no by not continuing production on the
entire show because it's fundamentally
better to lose money on one episode
instead of funding a multi-hour long
failure Marvel however didn't do this
and just green lated shows on the Fai
that the creatives were hopefully
competent enough to work on the project
the scripts were finished and passable
and in general they started floating
this notion that any issues they'd run
into in production they could fix in
post which is an utter nightmare for
anyone working in the industry it leads
to a lazy form of film making with not
enough planning being done and it also
sends VFX Artisan to a frenzy because
inexperienced directors are constantly
making changes on already finished shots
with VFX or producers are finally seeing
the finished product and are now
throwing in their own notes for changes
thus adding to the budget and forcing
those artists to Crunch even more when
people bash bad V effects in Marvel
movies and is this major reason as to
why these movies or shows are bad I just
feel Disconnected by the conversation
because the artists making these shots
are actually very talented and are being
rushed to finish their work most people
will always point out the bad VFX but to
be fair they do deliver some genuinely
great shots that look incredible at
times it just unfortunately breaks your
immersion when those occasional bad
shots do arise like it's been reported
that Marvel Productions are regularly
making changes on their projects right
up until the deadline which just seems
insane to me because with proper
planning and pre-product that should
never be the case your movie or show
should be perfectly planned out to the
point that you don't drive up the budget
of the show while simultaneously hurting
the quality however this takes time and
since Marvel Studios essentially had a
quot of about three shows a year they
didn't have the luxury of time so
therefore the quality started to tank
even though it seems counterproductive
to have a lack of planning and then go
through months of re- shoots all of this
amalgamates into Marvel feeling more
like a conveyor belt of content instead
of something something that is more
driven by creativity and passion we do
occasionally get those shows like Loki
and moonnight but other shows like w
division which were good clearly had
some really inconsistent patches like
the ending that just felt like a
complete mess or the obvious elephant in
the room that is secret invasion in
which Marvel just tossed $200 million
off to a group of creatives in hopes
that they'd return with a good show so
since we've essentially assessed the
absolute chaos behind the scenes at
Disney plus and why so much of their
content has been and lacking let's now
see how this impacts the streaming
service as a whole and the major issues
that creates going into the biggest
problem is that for both Marvel and Star
Wars Disney is flooding the market with
so much content to the point that they
are oversaturating and damaging their
brand now this is a very nuanced subject
that I'll elaborate on and there is
definitely another side to this coin and
that side is what James gun brings up
and that people aren't getting superhero
fatigue and instead they are getting bad
writing or bad story fatigue for me I I
pretty much agree with the sentiment
because if we kept getting s tier Marvel
content like winter soldier Thor
Ragnarok and Guardians of the Galaxy
then people would be perfectly happy
those movies were all refreshing and
told great stories that were imbued with
so much creativity and love and their
follow-ups were all generally pretty
good and I feel like Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 is living proof that people
aren't fatigued by overall superhero
movies like if I were to personally rank
phase 4 it would look something like
this and in comparison this is how I
would rank the first three phases which
is a pretty depressing contrast people
are much more aware to the deteriorating
quality of the content to the point that
reviews now make or break Marvel movies
that's why Ant-Man Quantum Mania did
poly at the box office because critics
and fans ripped that movie apart leaving
people on the fence to either skip it
entirely or wait until it comes out in
Disney plus despite Quanto Mania having
some hype marketing and that they were
introducing King as the new Big threat
so this waning quality paired with a
drastic uptick and content on Disney
plus is what's driving the community to
this burnt out view then another aspect
for the MCU in particular is that the
universe is exponentially expanding to
an alarming degree with so many new
characters and plot threads to the point
that it's overwhelming for every show
they seemingly create more Loose Ends
than they do for plot lines they
conclude to go through some examples one
division establishes four separate plot
lines some of which have no clear plan
for the future like white Vision being
set loose into the world Hawkeye oddly
sets up a lot lot of different plot
lines new characters sometimes show up
out of the blue like in She-Hulk where
Hulk randomly has a son now secret
Invasion introduces the most overpowered
character in the MCU who will show up at
some other point I guess and even shows
that are meant to be a miniseries end up
concluding on a cliffhanger actually
looking back at moonight I completely
forgot that this character became a
superhero then this isn't even bringing
into account the usual end credit scene
introductions for the movies at this
point it feels like cutting off the head
of a Hydra in which when one story ends
two more take its place on top of all of
this being compounded by Disney plus
adding more wood to the fire this does
vary per person because fansy watch
every show or movie may not care as much
but for casuals it's really uninviting
you now have to injust dozens of hours
of content just to understand where
these characters came from the Marvels
as an example features two characters
that originated in two separate shows
each over 4 hours long so to understand
the complexities and context for these
characters you need to watch their shows
or you have a situation like Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
where fans who didn't watch W division
were confused about why Wanda was
suddenly a villain the Marvels may not
require you to watch Miss Marvel and
Wanda Vision to understand these new
characters because they'll probably
reintroduce them in a new way that's
digestable for casual movie goers but
that notion will always be in the back
of your head that you're missing a part
of their story because at the end of the
day you miss an entire Arc that these
characters went on in their own shows
this state in comparison to the first
few phases were much more casual viewer
friendly all we had were a small handful
of characters that took on conflict that
wasn't too overwhelming from an
overarching story perspective the
Dynamics between these characters had a
significant amount of depth and were all
able to be explored to a good extent
like I'd honestly be surprised if we
ever get a deeply personal moment again
where Tony Stark found out that Bucky
killed his parents I know we're
primarily in a phase where we're setting
things up again but with so many more
characters it's hard to imagine them
getting back to that level of depth that
we had between Iron Man and Captain
America now I just shudder at the
thought of anyone trying to write or
direct the next Avengers movie because
the amount of characters has more than
doubled Infinity war did an excellent
job balancing out its cast of characters
but the question is will that still work
for the next Avengers movie if we bring
in every superhero we've been setting up
there's almost no way we can go back to
that level of detail from the earlier
phases because by doing that you'll have
to cut out a lot of screen time for
other Heroes which begs the question why
introduce so many if they aren't going
to be that important later on I know
this is a comic book thing where you
have like 100 characters but I'd argue
that's more unsustainable in a movie or
show setting people tend to want quality
over quantity and the current track
record for Disney plus has shown us that
we can't have both taking a look over at
Star Wars there are obviously many
issues for each project that generally
have to do with the writing but I want
to take a look at a larger problem with
their shows on Disney plus and that's
the lack of creative and new ideas for
the franchise now there are very few
like the Mandalorian but even that show
has devolved into bringing back likable
characters that in turn deteriorates
their strong payoff earlier in the story
every single show essentially takes
place within one time period of the
universe because that is where these
recognizable characters are and thus
more people will pay to watch it that's
just the sad truth because there's
nothing that will inherently draw on a
ton of viewers right away if a show
doesn't have major recognizable
characters in them like Ahsoka as an
example included Anakin Skywalker and
the entire fandom lost their Collective
minds and thought it was the best thing
ever so when Disney is at a Crossroads
of making original stories with new
characters or mining The Nostalgia of
fans with bringing back existing popular
characters you could probably guess
which path they will take it more or
less stifles creativity when he Force
future stories through a bottleneck when
there are so many other eras within the
universe you can explore Disney has said
that they're planning on doing that but
but given that they're cutting back on
producing more shows it's unclear how
many we're really going to get given
that Dave filon and John favro are
taking up a lot of the real estate the
acolyte is promising but that seems to
still be far away besides that the
current state of Star Wars has been
extremely rough and the only show that
has been truly great is Andor and sadly
that show didn't perform well because it
didn't have an iconic character backing
it and it also probably hurt that people
are burnt down on the rebel storyline
despite the show genuinely having some
outstanding dramatic writing so we're at
a point where the other half of content
on Disney plus has people mostly tired
of it and desperately wanting something
new and refreshing also it's not
necessarily A Bad Thing to tell stories
of existing characters like Obi-Wan the
issue however arises when someone
doesn't have an original or great vision
for the series and Disney forces and
rushes the show into existence or if
they do have a good Vision Disney May
step in Jerry riget into a happy
light-hearted miniseries when it was
supposed to be a darker movie akin to
Logan which in turn angers the fans who
want to love your franchise this is
essentially going into the next point in
that a lot of miniseries on Disney plus
feel like they would have been better
suited to be movies at a certain point
you have to ask yourself is it better to
have a 10050 to $200 million budget for
68 episodes that have unnecessary
elements in a slow pace or just condense
it down to a solid 2our plus movie that
is of a much higher quality because the
production value for a lot of these
shows feels cheap at times and that
really comes through for any action
Scene It has the rushed and lazy TV show
feel and this is felt the most in Star
Wars where lightsaber fights are
supposed to be elaborately crafted with
great choreography Dynamic movements on
inspiring settings and more but on a TV
show schedule and budget the creators
don't have enough time in rehearsal to
get footage that looks great so to
partially get around this the action is
in turn not as high effort leading to
what feels like an overall downgrade or
or narratively a lot of these shows were
initially being written as movies and
then management busted through the door
and saw potential to up Disney Plus's
catalog examples being Obi-Wan and
secret Invasion maybe then secret
Invasion could actually afford to
include more characters within its story
because that kind of premise desperately
needed more than just roie and Everett
Ross showing up but the reality is that
these actors are very expensive so even
though secret Invasion has a large
budget they sadly can't afford a large
roster of characters that the MCU has
which does seem kind of
counterproductive in that you've
introduced and brought in so many
characters but having multiple of them
in your shows or movies would be too
expensive because their price tags are
in the millions there are only a small
handful of shows like w division Loki
She-Hulk despite my dislike for it and
Anor that feel like they were
specifically made for TV and if they
were movies it would only be a downgrade
for their stories they earn their time
because every episode is extremely
productive in terms of its narrative and
how it grows their characters they have
wide sprawling and fun stories instead
of something that is stretched out to
fit six episodes looking at you John
favro the book of Boba Fett could have
easily just been a movie and maybe then
they'd actually try to make their action
scenes look half decent this seems to
primarily be the management of who's
running these shows because when you
look over at HBO shows like House of the
dragon that have a similar budget feels
significantly better and of a higher
quality than anything Disney plus has to
offer I used to think that it was just a
the directors who are butchering these
shows when in reality the fault probably
goes much higher and wider than that
although some directors are clearly
worse than others Disney plus does have
their occasional gems but most of them
seem to be isolated cases of Disney
stumbling onto a passionate creator that
genuinely want to make something
outstanding instead of their usual
current affairs where the studio comes
up with an idea and finds someone to
make it who doesn't have a story that's
deeply engaging the crazy thing is this
was essentially the Inception of the
awakens where Disney forced the sequel
to happen and the writers had no idea
what to do so they essentially just
copied A New Hope we're at a point where
people are starting to despise the two
types of content that Disney plus has to
offer and this goes into my final point
for Disney Plus's overall issues which
is simply Disney plus only has Marvel
and Star Wars content they basically
have no other highquality and sought
after original shows with unique stories
that people want to watch when you look
at every other platform their most
popular show tends to be an original
series that balloons into having immense
popularity like Netflix having stranger
things Apple having Ted lasso or
Severance Amazon Prime having the boys
and really any shows on HBO at this
point but for Disney plus they seem to
be putting all of their eggs into two
baskets and even shows that they do make
like Willow that aren't based on Marvel
or Star Wars they instantly cancel and
immediately remove off of their
streaming service as if they are deeply
embarrassed by it not saying that that
show was good or anything I don't think
anyone even watched that show or wanted
it it just seems like a baffling
decision to give an obscure and Niche IP
its own show with a $100 million budget
again going back to them probably
needing to make Pilots for their shows
and having higher quality assurance
currently the only big show coming out
on Disney plus that isn't Marvel or Star
Wars related is another adaptation of
Percy Jackson and the Olympians I hope
this show is good but given that Disney
plus has garnered a bad reputation for
lowquality shows I'm not exactly excited
for this series when normally I would be
it's kind of sad but you can only
disappoint fans for so long until they
cut ties to your streaming service which
is pretty surprising considering that
Disney plus has really only been around
for a few years so I don't necessarily
want to end this video on a depressing
and gloomy note of Disney plus and the
content they're making being terrible
because at least on the side of MCU
content they are making stries to do
better they're going to start hiring
showrunners for coming shows who have a
more consistent and Creative Vision so
that there isn't a constant frenzy
behind the scenes they're going to start
hiring more TV Executives so they aren't
stretched thin between movies and shows
it's rumored that Kevin foggy is going
to start hiring more tried and tested
talent instead of relative unknowns
mainly because by hiring new directors
there's a bit of uncertainty as to
whether they'll perform well so they end
up needing to be supervised more they've
also seemed to be hiring more
experienced writers like Nick pelato for
blade who was the writer for True
Detective and Leung Jin for Thunderbolts
R beef so they probably won't take
another chance on someone like Jeff
lovess again who wrote ant Manana Mania
because prior to that his primary
experience was writing some Rick and
Morty episodes then finally they're
going to start focusing on more
serialized TV this means shows will be
geared towards multiple Seasons instead
of miniseries that are unsure about
whether or not they're getting another
season so these four changes will
hopefully lead to better and more
fine-tuned shows on Disney plus the
writing itself will still be a major
indicator for Quality obviously but at
least the environment for making this
content won't be so hospitable also
another major change coming to Disney
plus is that it's going to be combined
with Hulu in an attempt to increase the
value of the overall package the main
reason this is happening is because
Disney plus hasn't made any money since
it started it's been operating at a
constant loss every quarter some of
which Disney has lost 500 million to
even a billion dollar this was honestly
a pretty major Revelation to me and it
also seems that the service is starting
to go down a spiral in that for the last
two quarters they reported losses for
subscribers Disney plus does have over
146 million subscribers which is the
third highest so it's kind of surprising
that they're losing this much money
probably points to the behind the scenes
of the service being even worse than
what we just went over in this video so
yeah I'll end it here since the video is
getting really long I didn't want to go
on an unhinged MCU rant I wanted to
provide some kind of New Perspective so
hopefully this video was informative in
some way thank you for watching and
check out my socials for letterbox
Discord and patreon in the
description